ramsay show you can be intentional about
your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
host of the ken coleman show
where he talks about careers and jobs
and getting
into a workplace that you love every day
is my co-host today ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book
the proximity principle again open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five now we talk all the
time ken
about the outgo side of the equation
okay what do you do first what do you do
a second baby step one baby step two
maybe step three
and we also talk about things that
aren't predictable
which is what happens when you're in the
thick of baby step two
and find out you or your spouse are
expecting
or about the time you start working on
your money stuff you lose your job
that can be scary very scary and so what
we do
is on the ken coleman show we're coming
at this big shovel thing
and and and the reality is when you all
listen and
watch the debt free screams that happen
every day on the ramsay show
you almost always see an increase in
income during that time and people go
hey
i got to go make more money to drive
that gazelle intensity
sometimes it's part-time jobs but
sometimes they just wake up and go you
know
i need to talk to my boss about a race
yeah or i don't really like this place
i'm gonna
i'm gonna go get a different job and
this yeah this but the whole getting out
of debt thing caused them to reassess
their careers that's exactly right
and doing what you love is possible
in fact dave you can make the income you
need and the impact you want
and that's what we talk about here at
ramsey solutions you you we talk about
work that matters here that's an anthem
that is on the big screen if you come in
and like we've got hundreds of people in
the lobby today
work that matters this is the idea of
doing something
that you're good at that you love and
that produces a result the product or
service whatever the company does
that means something to you and you can
actually pursue that
and you can get there even if you are
walking
through the baby steps and many times it
is that pursuit which makes you more
money which gets you out of debt faster
so let's go to the other side of the
equation from the that's the maximized
self-actualization side let's go the
other side like i need some money to eat
because i lost my job that's right
i need somebody to eat right now that's
right so you want to focus
on just getting some money that's right
so here's what you do you you lock that
into one part of that three-part
equation you go what do i do really well
those think of those as power tools when
you show up to do a project at home you
want the best tools
because you do the work more effectively
and that's what you have to offer the
marketplace
you focus on hey i'm really gifted here
i've got some talent and if i
if i offer this talent or i make this
talent sharper
and i turn into a premium tool guess
what i'm going to get paid more
i'm going to have more opportunities
maybe even side hustle to make even more
money
so when it's just i need a better job to
pay me more to get out of debt
focus on that talent part that's what
you were created to do because you're
really good at that's where you can make
money quick
quick right now and get started right
now and get to get the wolf away from
that
then we can pivot we get out of debt and
we go okay
now i've been putting everything in your
start asking questions like when can i
start when's the first paycheck
i mean because i'm like i'm hungry right
now that's right so what you have to
focus on is what you bring to the
marketplace that you do really well
because people will
see that and they will pay you for that
and then after we get out of debt get
that baby step 3 fully funded
now we can begin to look at what's the
transition to do work that i really love
that produces the results so
we're going to help you wherever you are
on the journey big shovel hey
let's get that shovel bigger so we get
out of debt faster live like no one else
so we can live give and work like no one
else yeah
it's all the hole that you're in is the
mess that you've made
and we always call it the shovel to hold
ratio that's exactly you know
i have sixty thousand dollars in debt
okay
i'll make twenty thousand dollars a year
oh oh that's right or i have sixty
thousand dollars of debt and i make two
hundred thousand dollars a year oh big
shovel that's right
look you know medium sized hole yeah uh
tiny shovel
big hole you know i mean the the shovel
to hole ratio
will give you an indication how quickly
you're going to get out of that
how quickly you can put these financial
hard times behind you that's right and
so
we often say stuff like you need a
bigger shovel that's right
one of the ways to get that doesn't
always mean leaving in a career
you could just get promoted that's stage
five of my seven stages to doing
work you love stage five is get promoted
how do you promote it well you gotta
know your role get really clear
was the last time you had a conversation
with your leader to say what is expected
of me i want to win here
help me understand how i can drive more
results leaders don't get that
conversation much
and you might be surprised how they go
wow that's awesome
because if you're winning folks guess
what they're winning
and so get promoted hey here's another
thing develop some qualities
what are the most promotable qualities
according to linkedin right now
in 2021 you ready for this dave it's
adaptability
so hey you know what that means that's a
fancy multiple syllable word that
basically means
i can handle change and as you know
change is hard for all of us
why because change makes us confront the
unknown
man i just i don't even want i do not
make me get another phone
right i have to learn quickly over again
yeah
put another and they just put new
software on my dad blame computer this
week and it's just
i think i'm gonna office space the thing
only with a 45 caliber oh my god
i don't like change i'm not i'm not
promotable i'm not adaptable i hate this
crap right
that's right and yet you're a ceo how
important is it
actually i am adaptable i know you when
it comes to freaking technology that's
right your squares are different colors
on this computer folks
shut up everybody say it for dave he's
struggling right now just shut up but
see adaptability
adaptability is a learnable skill it's a
muscle
okay wait a second in in this economy
with technology
uh always advancing so i want adaptable
people does that
include the thing of uh i'll help with
it even though it's not my job is that
adaptability you better believe it
because it's you know there was the old
thing the old guy uh back in the 70s
there was a sitcom and the guy would go
not my job man it's not my job that's
right it's not my job that's right and
you're
you know i'm always in so i'm always
amazed when i go in some business
and you can't beg them to take your
money yeah you know
and and you're looking at three people
standing there looking at you and you're
like
you take my money that's like it's not
my job man that's right i'm here to do
something else no by god you're here
because the money
yes yeah yeah it is your job
adaptability really is an attitude
i mean we call it ability adaptability
but really is an attitude that says you
know what
change is a part of life it's going to
make me uncomfortable it's a great book
written on
change and that's who moved my cheese
fabulous book for anybody who wants to
really develop this muscle
but adaptability is just one quality
that makes you promotable here's another
one likability
how about just being more likable how
about reliability
don't look like you're weaned on a
pickle that's right smile you talk about
this all the time hey
you're happy to notify your face yeah
have a conversation with somebody
hey leaders if you want to move up the
leadership ladder here's two questions
you're ready for this one hey talk to
your people regularly and ask them these
two questions
number one how are you doing and it's
not the how you doing when we cross each
other in the hallway that's a greeting
and everybody just goes great great and
then we move on it's sitting down with
them on their desk
intentionally having a meeting with
going hey how you doing how are the kids
how's everything going how's everything
going in the gig here and that leads to
the second question which is
how can i help you win you want to get
promoted as a leader
ask those two questions on a regular
basis and watch your effectiveness as a
leader
and the impact you have on your people
absolutely
skyrocket because the first one's about
connection dave the second question
is they trust you now and they will
begin to tell you hey
here's how you can help me win and
that's what leadership is all about
so the idea is you can be shiny
or you can be dull yeah you just and you
just need to decide to be shiny be shiny
and watch the money come in
watch the because people are like bass
they go after shiny stuff
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
the proximity principle is my co-host
today as we talk about your careers
your jobs your life and your money mark
is with us in
casper wyoming hi mark welcome to the
show
hey thanks a lot guys first of all i
want to thank both of you
for faithfully following god's call on
your life well thank you changing lives
out here
thank you it's kind of cheating but it's
good yeah
that's great well i'll get right to it
um
my mom uh went home to be with the lord
in april oh my goodness
and uh so yeah it's still a little fresh
yeah but um you know she's a faithful
servant of god
and a wonderful mother and uh i know
exactly where she's at i look forward to
seeing her again here soon
[Music]
now the the other side of it is she
ended up
graciously gifting me 20 acres
with a small house on it it's just
outside of this popular resort town
here in wyoming now i understand that
this is a wonderful gift
and uh i want to manage it
well for the lord i understand that you
know this is god's property
and i want to make sure that i do the
right thing but uh you know it's a
big responsibility for me biggest i've
ever had and i'm concerned
because i think that we may be in a real
estate bubble so
my question is you know should i
consider selling this property at what i
perceive to be a high
and reinvest proceeds elsewhere or
should i start developing some sort of
plan to
to generate a return on the property uh
while it potentially appreciates some
time
did she live in the house she did not
okay are you you got any other than the
fact your mom
just recently passed and left it to you
do you have any other emotional ties to
the property
it is where i grew up so i do have oh
you know a bit of emotional tie too yeah
yeah
that's right in the old farm that's not
a bit that's real yeah
okay so i mean when you sell it there's
a little boy inside of you that's gonna
cry a little
yeah yeah that's just i mean you need to
say that out loud if you're going to
sell it
uh the other thing is the other time
that little boy's going to cries if you
put a renter in there and they tear it
up
true it's really weird to have renters
in the property that you once
occupied it's an emotional experience
i've done it many times
but it i first time or two it caught me
off guard and i went you know that was
my little boy's bedroom and
and now you put that crap in there i
mean what is going on you know i mean
it's like you know
it feels weird you know so um
you either way you're gonna face a
little bit of that and you need to be
prepared for that
i uh uh real estate bubbles uh
happen when something goes up and
doesn't
uh and then obviously goes down because
it went up
too fast or went up faster than the
marketplace would support
by and large in the us right now we are
seeing tremendous real estate inflation
i that is not a bubble
that's not going to come back down um
the only time we've had a nationwide
bubble
where real estate went down nationwide
in the last 100 years was 2008.
one time it has happened in a hundred
years so i do not think that
that nationwide bubble now resorts
or you said is near a resort town
resorts have a problem in that they're
more volatile
than traditional housing and that kind
of thing so if the if the value that's
placed on it right now is because of its
proximity to the resort
you know yeah that could bubble on you
that could dip later
so uh i i
what do you want aside from the fact
that you're afraid the property
might be maxed out what do you want to
be do you want to be owning that or
something else 10 years from today
okay so 10 years from today you know i i
would love to be able to go back
and um renovate the house and maybe live
there
um you know that's been a dream of mine
but i i don't know
realistically realistically if i'm in a
financial position to own
it's it's uh you know it's a trophy
property
what's it worth it's worth probably 1.5
million okay
why do you feel you're not in a position
to own it when it's been gifted to you
well this is you know i'm trying to get
out of my own head and look at this
and the way i perceive it is if i had a
bank account with a million and a half
dollars in it
i make about 70 grand a year right now
but i work
60 70 hours a week would i
would i go and buy that trophy piece of
property
with if i had a million point five sure
doesn't have any real
income on it right yeah okay yeah i
wouldn't
i i think you're selling it and i don't
think that's unwise
but i think you can expect some sadness
when you do
that's human nature and there's nothing
wrong with that this is personal
finance so i think you're selling it and
um
you're going to reduce your hours and
you may use some of this money to do
some career adjustment things if you
want to
oh yeah you may use some of this when
you start a business you may use some of
this money to buy some property
and um other property that is that is
income producing because this is not
going to produce income
with one little house on 20 acres of raw
ground uh
sufficient to justify me and a half
dollar investment it's not an income
property
it's not it's not how it's designed so
um my guess is you're gonna be doing a
little bit of all of those things
with this money and moving very very
slow with the money once you get it
but i'm with you i'm okay selling a
trophy property at this time of the
market uh it's not a bad time to do it
at all actually
yeah but it is emotional it is and i was
gonna ask you you know
how how does he square the emotion of
this was a dream this was a dream to go
back and live in that home
uh but also square it with his mother
inherit
give gave him that as an inheritance
it's going to change his life
dramatically
and receive the gift from that
standpoint this is a life-changing
sale and you know what enters into this
in my mind too is
his strong statement about his faith is
mom's faith uh which
means that his mom held the property
probably with an open hand like he did
and he's learned that from her and so
he's not
um you know you're not freaking out
about this
that that was all in his words his word
choice is pausing
everything was there it was all
indicated there so he's got a calmness
about this due to his faith
and his uh yeah i'm just a manager i'm
not an owner i'm a steward yes
and i i'm okay what's the smart thing
before the lord what's god want me to do
with this
yeah and um you know uh you don't have
to make a decision fast
there's nothing rushing you but i think
you're probably selling it
yeah i agree i think it's such a
life-changing opportunity yeah and uh
wow and receive that yeah don't feel
guilty about that nothing wrong with
that at all
yeah summer's almost here it does not
mean you can take a vacation from your
money goals i know the motivation to
stay in tents can go away sometimes
especially when you want that beach trip
or all the fun things that come
with summer uh you can do this though
it's about getting small wins
with your money that lead to big results
with your money
over time and that's exactly what you'll
do with ramsey plus live like no one
else so that later you can live and give
like no one else
ramsay plus membership gives you our
best digital money courses
of course including financial peace
university the tools that you need to
keep moving forward
of course including every dollar premium
the world's best budgeting app your
goals are worth
working for all year long stay motivated
with a free trial
of ramsey plus text trial to 33
789 text trial 2 three
three seven eight nine
so i i think it's like uh
you make different decisions when you
hold things the way that
mark was holding them if you hold your
career
with an open hand instead of this
tight-fisted white knuckling
if you hold a car if you hold an
investment
if you hold a business uh an asset
of any kind with an open hand um and say
gosh i don't really own this i'm just
managing it for god
what is the best thing it changes your
decision-making paradigm because
when if i'm managing something on your
behalf ken
i'm a little bit more responsible
sometimes than i might be if i was
managing it for myself
it's absolutely the case i feel the
obligation to do a good job
for you that's right and so as a person
of faith as a christian when you say
god owns it i'm managing it for someone
else what do you want
you ask the owner what he wants to do
with it
it's a whole different thing and you
know so the heat and air goes out on
your house you go hey god
you know you're heating air's out buddy
i need a miracle i like that approach
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today nicholas and rebecca are
in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt-free stage hey guys how are
you
we're good how are you better than i
deserve welcome where do you all live
gastonia north carolina about 20 minutes
from charlotte oh fine
good to have you guys and all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free screen yes
sir
how much did you pay off 36 000 wow and
how long did this take
14 months good for you and your range of
income during that time
about 50 000 good what do y'all do for a
living
i got a new job i work at chick-fil-a
i'm an elementary school teacher
oh fun what grade do you teach i teach
first but i'm moving to preschool this
year
they don't back talk so rachel's
oldest one was over at the house of the
night and and she i said so
uh you're going into first grade next
year and she said no pop i'm going to
second grade i said no baby you're going
into the first grade
yeah she said no i'm going in the second
round she convinced me
and then she's not she was completely
pulling my leg i like it she's like her
mother man she can talk
she's amazing so that's a cute age
though that's so fun
so 36 000 worth of debt
what was it 6 000 was credit card and 30
with student loans
okay all right how long y'all been
married um a year and two months
oh like 14 months yeah
so you get married and come home from
the honeymoon and go game on we're
getting out of debt
yep how did that happen what got you so
fired up
uh well it was probably about 2019 that
summer
uh we were engaged my body was like hey
like we're doing this class at church
it's called financial peace i'm like
what is that like this is going to be
weird and
we're like all right we'll do it so in
september is when we took it
and as soon as we watched it from day
one
we were all out wow so that got you
going
twice yeah we actually took it twice
that's not a bad thing no
the first time was in um february of
that year
and i was like yes like let's do this
now look over here she's like
no i like you now
the now party yeah
did you not like when you first took it
you were resistant what was so tough for
you
um i am a control freak
i like to be able to do like what i want
to do with my money and
it made me realize that this is what i
want to do with my money oh it's god's
money
um so we had to make it your idea
that's when you did it i like it i like
it that's real
that's good i love that that's really
good yeah you had
you had to want to do it yeah i don't
blame you i like that that's smart
very smart on your part so what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you did it
well i listened to this every day i've
listened to for the last couple years
and i hear all these different stories
but
when i sat down with rebecca when we
first got married i said
before we sit down before we do our
budget before we talk about anything
we're going to give a full 10 to church
we're going to tithe
and that's the best thing we ever did
along with budgeting
god has really blessed us we've gotten
things in the mail
unexpected things and it's just really
seen the progressive
of how our life has been through
marriage
i get unexpected things in the mail too
but they're not they're not the ones you
can cash like a check yeah
that's fun look at you guys i'm so proud
of y'all
well done man that's fun it's a big deal
there is something about uh for those of
us that are believers to begin to tithe
a full 10 of your income to your local
church if
something snaps inside of your spirit
when you do that that uh
you just get things get loose it's
pretty cool yep
yeah was there a big challenge or was
there something that was really hard
when you guys went all in on this
the pandemic oh yeah hello yeah there's
that
right you're kidding what was tough we
got married um
i'm sorry no you're good we got married
the day the stay at home order started
in our
state so we had to redo
everything we thought we were going to
do for our wedding
no honeymoon we did it in his parents
backyard
so yeah it's been a journey just
you know they say finances is like a
number one argument but i felt like we
went into it
after taking financial peace and like
actually had peace about it yeah
yeah you bet you had a lot of challenges
yeah that's pretty amazing
yeah but what do i mean gosh i mean
you're gonna be like old people
back when we got married it was a
pandemic you know you'll be telling your
great-grandkids
this story yeah this is great we're
gonna get married in the backyard
[Laughter]
is there a honeymoon on the way now that
you're debt-free well we went to the
well yeah but we went to the beach um
just for the weekend though
um back for a one year anniversary
though and maybe
in the future we'll do something all
right good awesome
well you're doing so great i'm so proud
of y'all what a great start
yep we actually um we got a house
all right yeah so we're going to close
um
in june and we'll have a mortgage and we
have 15 year loan and we're going to pay
off
super early man that's amazing well done
you guys
very very well done
is winning right here man well done 50
000 income and all of this accomplished
in 14 months
pretty stinking impressive very very
well done
very well done we've got a copy of the
legacy journey
book which is your next step to become
wealthy and
outrageously generous and you are well
on your way because you've been very
intentional you guys are heroes
very very proud of you very good job you
took control
you took control of your life you're a
control freak i like it me too
me too so well done and another copy of
the total money makeover book as well
eight million of those out there now and
you'll have that one to give away to a
friend and
uh hopefully pay it forward get somebody
else started on your journey because
they're going to be inspired by your
lives
because your lives are inspiring so well
done that's right
you guys i could see the peace all over
you yeah financial peace is a real thing
when you can see it on somebody yeah
and the t-shirts help with the living
debt-free t-shirts and they're color
coordinated his and hers i mean they're
on top of it yeah this is
this is like a whole thing here it's a
whole picture i like it well done
all right nicholas and rebecca from
charlotte north carolina 36
000 paid off in 14 months
14 months married making 50 000.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
you know the first time that a thousand
years ago that someone said you know i i
really don't like you
um yeah how'd that feel i thought i
thought it was me that they didn't like
and
it's not me it's me telling them what to
do yeah or me and they don't want to do
what we're talking about i don't like
dave ramsey
which means translation and they don't
even know me they're not they're not
they don't like me
it's like i'm telling you be on a budget
live unless you make be a grown up be
mature not spend money you don't have
don't act like you're in congress
i'm telling you all these kinds of
things and that's what people don't like
nobody likes to be told they
can't do no and see the reality is this
whole phrase the truth
hurts oh i thought it set you free well
there's that one too yeah okay too too
long of a pause
but the truth hurts and so here's the
deal they hear the truth
and it hurts it stings and so then they
go oh dave's telling the truth i don't
like dave
he's he's a boomer
[Laughter]
he's just a boomer yeah he's just it
really is true
it uh it hurts i really am a boomer who
yeah well you're true that's true too
but uh you know it is fun to see i mean
this couple it's just they're on fire
there's so much peace all over them the
happiness the joy
and here's the deal that you know you're
gonna have to accept a little bit of
pain
i don't know of any area of life where
we get progress without some pain
i just don't know of an area if you want
progress whether it's money
whether it's in your work whether it's
in your uh
your health relationships if you want to
keep progressing keep growing and
head somewhere worth going it's gonna be
tough
and these baby steps time in time out
day in day out they work and it is
painful
but boy what it produces on the other
end is just pure unadulterated joy and
we're looking at it
yeah i remember rachel was a little baby
upstairs asleep and we were going broke
uh denise was a toddler upstairs to
sleep it's three o'clock in the morning
i had my bible open
romans 5. rejoice in your suffering yeah
and i went i don't think i will no thank
you
it's not a good idea rejoice in your
suffering because suffering produces
perseverance yes
perseverance character character hope
and hope
that's what's all over their faces
that's exactly right
that one was the scripture said i just
thought of that though this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five two matt is in charlotte
north carolina hi matt welcome to the
show
hey dave hey ken thanks so much for
having me today sure what's up
um well first of all i love that story
from the debt free stage my wife and i
also had a pandemic wedding and it was a
great excuse to spend
very very little on a wedding i think
between the wedding and the honeymoon we
spent about
five thousand dollars and we did it on a
fishing pier at a local park
with my buddy who was an army chaplain
so i think i think that was really
awesome
serious fun yeah definitely so
dave the reason that i called in today i
just wanted to say first you have
helped me out so much my wife and i are
29 we're debt-free accept the house with
150 000
in savings and i'm at a point now where
i really want to start giving back but i
feel as though all i have right now is
knowledge and time um and i want to do
something that i love in my spare time
when i'm not working and i truly believe
in the old adage of
teaching a man to fish right and what
i'd really like to get involved in
is um educating youth talking about
middle schoolers to high schoolers
um on financial independence and you
know
financial responsibility because as you
know financial education is
you know pretty wanting in the education
system right now
i'm an educator a trainer and a leader
at heart that's probably comes from my
time in the army
and what i'm curious to know is is how
would you go about this
would it make sense to set up a
non-profit or
become an independent contractor and try
to sell my services to school districts
and then if there are any licenses that
you think i would need
or resources you think i should you know
tie myself
into um this is something that i'd like
to do on the side as a way to give back
but i'm just looking for some creative
thoughts from your from from your angle
yeah um you know i
i always recommend just start and don't
i wouldn't worry about some
massive marketing or legal
strategy or structure i would just call
some math teachers and say hey can i
come in one day and talk to your kids
about finances
and um i am on my off time
and uh you know you don't charge for it
you don't you just go in there and do it
uh and just kind of just start
um that's how we have a high school
curriculum and a middle school
curriculum
that is now taught on finances now
taught in 48 percent of the high schools
in america
so um you could give our guys a call and
find out some of the teachers that are
teaching our stuff
and um you could just go into those
classrooms and volunteer to answer
questions for kids and
you know you know do a live presentation
because the presentation's with me on
video obviously might me and the
ramsey personalities coleman's in it and
all that you don't have to do that but
i'm just saying that's somebody's
where a door is already open on the
subject and you could supplement
just to kind of get your feet wet and
get started and then you'll start to
figure out
maybe ways to form your business model
and that might
inform you as to whether it's a a
business that's a ministry or whether
it's a non-profit
that's a ministry and um
but you've got certainly got the the bug
and that's a good thing and
you have identified the truth and that
is that the educational system needs a
lot of help with this subject
i've been working on it for 20 years and
i'm still only 48 in
i mean it's it's it's a lot of work and
a lot a lot of people need help and so
you know i'm happy to help you guy help
you do that help you move forward and do
all that
um it is um ken
he's followed your stuff to a t and that
he he figured out what he's good at
yeah and he's figuring out a way to do
it in a way that it makes him
happy yeah i wrote down matt what you
said all i have is knowledge and time
and i want you to rephrase that and say
i have knowledge and i have time and i
think you first start with how much time
do i really have
when you've got a big heart like this
and you can just feel the desire
coming out of you to help people that's
a wonderful thing so let's slow down our
emotions and let's go okay
how much time given the fact that i'm
married i got a full-time job how much
time do i have a week i think it's a
great exercise let's just say for
example purposes dave it's
five hours uh and so you come up with
that uk i've got that time and i
certainly have the knowledge and you
have passion by the way you can hear it
all over you
so now to dave's point i love the
volunteering put yourself out there and
just start
start actually helping young people i
would look at multiple different places
in your zip code by the way too
not just the classroom and dave's right
the foundations
and personal finance we've already given
you the curriculum our video team is
world class
you could press play and then instruct a
little bit based off of that answer
questions
and really provide a wonderful service i
would look at
uh churches uh other non-profit
organizations that are serving young
people
so you have a heart for young people so
i would ask in charlotte north carolina
or your zip code where are the young
people
who is serving them that becomes your
list so it's not as intimidating when i
go oh
there are multiple organizations and
multiple sectors
in my area whether that be a ymca
or a government agency that's serving
all those places one of the first places
i taught what the bible says about money
was a youth group yeah
at our church i sat down with 25 kids in
the youth group and showed them what
what the scripture said about it and
then i taught a college age group
yeah and that actually uh formed into
a an adult group but i was one of the
first places i ever did it yeah the
thing is
if you're if you want to be a writer
start writing
yeah if you want to be a runner you
should run this morning
you know if you want to be a if you want
to teach personal finance and help kids
you should just start doing it that's
right and you don't need to wait till
you have a non-profit form you don't
need to wait till you have the
figured out how to charge for it just go
do it some
do it and it'll you know as you interact
with the educators as you interact with
the kids you're going to start to see
what's working what's not
how to charge for it whether to charge
for it whether we're going to bring in
underwriters and sponsored as a
non-profit or whether we're going to
actually you know charge the school
system a fee that's exactly right and by
just looking at all the different places
that i was talking about there and
asking yourself who are the kids i most
want to help yeah
your heart's going to begin to fill in
the answers and dave is absolutely right
matt
just start and then what you're going to
find is it's almost like
going through a maze as you begin to
walk forward you're going to walk into a
wall move left move right keep walking
jennifer's in philadelphia hi jennifer
welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you for taking my call sure
speak with you
um so let's make this quick my husband
and i
took financial peace university two
years ago
i've been really working to get out of
debt i have been wanting to go to your
ontario leadership summit since i've
learned about you
and and then now we'll be totally debt
free
at um by october possibly december but
it looks like october
or this year so i'm calling to see can i
buy my ticket
to summit that's coming up in orlando or
should i wait
until we're totally debt free and then
we buy the ticket next you know for the
following time because if i don't do it
now
i'll have to wait till next you know i
just been putting off year after year
i'm you know just getting excited i'm
close
i appreciate that and i'm really honored
that you want to come
it would be very hypocritical of me to
tell you to buy our stuff
while you're getting out of debt and i
tell people not to do anything like that
but our stuff our stuff's different no
you you really shouldn't
you know that's why i was calling but
you know i'm excited for you i want you
to come too
um and uh so you know i
but but it's uh it's an expensive ticket
i mean they're what three four thousand
dollars right
right and uh that's an expensive ticket
and i i just go
right right it would be it would just be
completely lacking in integrity for me
to tell you to do that so no i would not
do that
i would wait until you're out of debt
before you spend that kind of money on
uh you know education uh and
which is what summit is it's teaching
world-class leadership
uh it's one of the best leadership we
just came back from dallas it was
absolutely incredible
and uh it's it is probably the best
leadership event
on the planet right now it's absolutely
incredible
there's not a lot of leadership planning
events left yeah but it is even
when there's a lot it's it's a one the
only one doing it so we're definitely
the best
but uh yeah but yeah i uh
uh you know we welcome you when you're
able to do it in the right way
and i i i cannot in good conscience
recommend that you do that while you're
working your baby step two but thank you
for the call
yeah that's some and the thing is
i i was uh listening to actually the
entree leadership
podcast this morning on my run and we
had a guy on there talking about sales
and he's going you have to
believe so much in your product i do
believe in that product i think it's
worth a whole lot more
than what we charge for without question
and it's going to benefit her
more than that but i'm still not still
not going to tell her to do it
no but here's the deal turn that into an
extra motivation she's already gazelle
intense she's almost there she can see
the finish line
add that is like after the old marathon
i'm going to go get a big pizza whatever
you got to do turn it into motivation
there you go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
ken talks about careers and jobs i talk
about money and together we will just
talk about you
right in front of you the phone number
triple eight eight two five
five two two five curt is in fort
lauderdale florida
hi curt how are you hey dave how you
doing
better than i deserve man what's up
how you doing um i'm 25. i'm not filled
with my job and i'd like to move out of
my parents house
potentially looking up north but i have
about 50 000 in investments and 90 000
in my savings and i'm blessed to have no
debt um
should i move with the current housing
market situation should i
wait if i should wait should i move some
of that savings money into
investment make some money while i'm
waiting
well um the housing market is as you
mentioned is
quite hot in terms of buying a home uh
some areas the rental market is also
closed up
and it's very difficult to find a rental
and so rental prices are going up as
fast as
real estate prices are which there
should be a correlation between the two
that makes sense
so uh
you have done a wonderful job saving
money sir
well done you save all this money or
somebody give it to you
um i'd say about half maybe a little
less than half of an inheritance from my
uncle arrested all just me saving
uh my my father and my mother since i
was young have always told me you know
spend half save half and i just was
never really a big spender so i saved
more than half of that point um
and so i've just been saving uh for i've
been working since i was
you know 16. so i've been saving for a
while now and i'm just
i've always been looking forward to
buying a house and i just was feeling
that was the right time but with this
housing market i'm just
it kind of shot down my house you said
you might move up north what are you
going to do for a living when you move
i'd stay within the same industry but
right now i probably go more
analytics that's what i like to do right
now i do
more risk management um so encourage
you know get into more analytical so i'm
glad we've identified this because
moving up north i think you had in mind
there's some companies or a company or a
specific job and i think that's the part
we want to work on first is
you're not happy in your job and so you
know
the good news is you're clear you know
what you want to do you have a good idea
of the analytics is where you want to go
i think i determined that where's a good
place to land there then i'd make my
housing decision based on that
okay so do you have a good idea of some
companies or do you have something when
you say move north or you just think in
an area
or are you thinking company that's
pulling you north
um i was thinking more just orlando or
jacksonville because i have a current
social
networks there that would you know in
finding a job there's
obviously a lot of within my industry
there's a lot in orlando and jackson
right i was looking there just to kind
of get away from where i was
where i've currently been where i've
lived all my life you know sure well
that's really good strategy
so kurt i i think you now you need to
take some action steps
and so i've i would begin if you haven't
already you obviously have the social
networks there
i would actually begin to engage those
social networks around those companies
you identified both friends connections
and uh several companies that are in
your industry at least you know that
it's pretty hot there
i'd start making those connections i'm
going to give you a copy of my number
one bestselling book the proximity
principle which actually walks you
through
step by step how to make those
connections who specifically you're
looking at
because i think if you get really
serious about that kurt right now you're
in great shape financially
let's find those opportunities let's go
ahead and get interviews let's land the
gig
and i think the housing decision uh will
take care of itself because you've been
really smart with your money but let's
land a job and then let's make a housing
decision as a part of that
yeah here's what i i will just add to
that let's take that i'll take the back
end of that strategy
so start working the social networks
you're only a few hours from those towns
get the job landed then go rent an
apartment for six months
then during that six months start
looking for property don't
overpay you there's no reason for you to
have house fever
you can take your time and if the
market's quite hot and you have to
dramatically overpay to get a house then
that's god's saying don't buy a house
right now
just wait take your time sit in that
apartment
in the new job in the new city and take
your time you've got the money you can
pounce
when you see the right thing you're in a
position to do it but don't get the
fever
and pounce especially on your very first
home purchase and overpay
after you've done such a great job
saving money so very very well done sir
good job anita is with us in dayton ohio
hi anita how are you
i'm fine thank you and thank you for
taking my call sure what's up
i am getting ready to retire and i have
about i'm going to take a plop
of 84 000. and i wasn't sure where to
put that money
okay no i was is that your only mistake
no no i have um my husband and i have a
couple hundred thousand in uh annuities
and i have a fifty thousand dollar
emergency fund
and then we have about um
right at two something in uh
just uh invested okay
all right well i'm definitely the 84 000
is coming from a lump sum
from a pension plan rollover or what yes
yes i would roll it to a traditional
ira that way there's no taxes on it and
i personally would put it in good mutual
funds so again just invest it you've
been doing investing
and i would just continue that with this
particular money
[Music]
if you pull it out you're going to be
taxed on it and if you're uh
over if you're under 59 uh which it
sounds like you're retiring so i doubt
it but i'm if you're under 59 you'll be
penalized as well so
no need to do any of that let's just
roll it and let the whole amount work
for you
in a traditional ira uh in some good
growth stock mutual funds that's the
best way to go
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you're
talking about that peak real estate
man real estate season is here if you're
thinking about buying a home this year
here's a piece of simple advice that
could save you from making a six figure
mistake
don't buy something you don't understand
if you don't know where to start and
you're unsure financially
you don't know if you're ready for a
mortgage you're confused about how the
buying process works start by connecting
with one of our endorsed local providers
these are high octane high protein real
estate agents
that we have vetted that we trust our
elps will help
guide you through the entire home buying
or home selling process
they're here to teach you every step of
the way
so that you feel confident in this big
money decision
go to ramseysolutions.com agent and
connect with one of our trusted
elps that's ramsey solutions dot com
slash agent
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today sarah is in milwaukee hi
sarah welcome to the ramsey show hi
thank you for having me sure what's up
so my husband and i have a disagreement
about how
about our mortgage so we
qualified for a 30-year mortgage but our
plan is to pay it off
like a 15. my husband in the budget
recommended to me in our last finance
meeting together
that whatever extra money we have in our
budget we should
put towards the principle of our
mortgage
and i'm like well honey um we only plan
on being in this house for five
maybe 10 years because we want more kids
and we need more space
and he's like no no no we really need to
pay towards the principal we need to own
more
of our house and it's cause there's huge
risks in our relationship
why is it causing a huge rift in your
relationship
what do you want to do with the money
um i would like to put it towards trips
or improving the house that we already
have
okay that's a fair that's a fair
argument then
okay um so uh the answer is you need to
do some of both
you're both right okay
i wasn't expecting that answer yeah
you're out of debt right except your
house
oh yeah okay and you have your emergency
fund are you putting 15
of your income into retirement
um we're about there yes okay are you
putting anything aside for your kids are
you putting anything aside for the kids
college
yes we are good okay that's baby steps
four five and six baby step six is pay
off your house early
now what you're supposed to do is to do
baby according to what we teach in other
words
is uh is to do baby steps four five and
six
simultaneously so you're putting 15
of your income away for retirement
you're putting money on your kids
college and you're supposed to be paying
down the house
um you know reasonably aggressive now
baby steps one through three
you do with gazelle intensity like a
gazelle running from a cheetah wide open
scared to death going crazy baby steps
four five and six
are not with intensity
they are with intentionality and baby
steps four five and six is where you buy
a couch where you fix up the house where
you go on a trip
and where you work on these other three
goals of retirement
kids college and and reducing the
mortgage and so
yeah i'd love for you i think it's wise
for you to reduce your mortgage
uh but i also think it's wise for you to
enjoy some money during these steps as
well and that would include
some reasonable renovations that you do
with cash no debt
some reasonable trips that you do with
cash and no debt if you consume
all the money and do no mortgage
reduction that would be unwise
but if you put a hundred percent on
mortgage reduction that's not what we
teach
okay so i would just figure out some how
much money are we talking about that's
in play here
a month how much a month does he want to
put on the mortgage and you're wanting
to spend
um i think it's about 500 to a thousand
dollars we have extra
okay in our budget okay well to start
with
the fact that you don't know that is a
problem
you need to know that you need to know
what's going on and 500 to a thousand
it's not it's one or the other
or it's 642 or i don't know i mean you
have a budget
and you have an amount left over that
we're arguing about and we don't even
know how much that is
so right now we're just having a vague
argument so the two of you need to sit
down and say okay
exactly because he's the nerd and you
don't nerd out on details but you need
to know enough of the details to know
what you're arguing about
right right i agree okay
so you jump in there you get figure out
and if it's uh 750 dollars and you say
all right we're going to put 350 on the
mortgage and we're going to set 400
aside for fun
and that fun this month is i'm going to
start we're going to start saving up to
fix up this bathroom and i want to spend
4 thousand dollars on it so it's going
to take 10 months of doing that
you know or whatever the thing is i
don't care what you do but um
if it's a thousand dollars and you want
to split a 50 50. i don't care
you know if you split down the middle or
what you do but the point is is that you
have a valid a very valid complaint here
a very valid argument
that you should not only do the proper
smart things with money and never enjoy
money that is
not what we you you're not going to get
there doing that you need to enjoy some
of it
but on the other hand he's got a valid
point that we need to put some on the
mortgage
and we don't need to just consume all of
our access
and so some of both is where wisdom
lands and that's where i would send you
to
good question it's a really good
discussion
and i think that people get a lot of
confusion around that
because we teach you to do live on rice
and beans don't see the inside of a
restaurant don't go on vacation when
you're in baby steps one through three
yeah i love the way you worded that the
intensity in baby steps one through
three
turns into intentionality which is we've
got a budget
but we can sit down and go hey we need
to get a whole new living room set
because the dogs have ruined it so we're
gonna save up for that so that
intentionality is still the budget
sounded like that might have really
happened
i did you nailed that we had to do that
uh recently because the uh
doodles uh big dogs come with big dog
problems but anyway the point is is that
i really like that differentiation there
that you have
laid out that's that's really the tone
you go from intensity to
okay now we can be intentional and still
enjoy life
oh and i'll just add one more thing to
it it doesn't have to be all or nothing
in a
month and i mean it doesn't have to be
split down the middle of the month you
could say
uh this month we're going to spend it
all all right
next month we're going to put it all on
the mortgage that's that's exactly right
you know you can you can go back and
forth a little bit
or we're going to for two months we're
going to set it all to buy this
furniture
and then for the next two months we're
going to do the mortgage i don't care
how you do it but
some of each needs to occur yeah
i really like that that that's a really
great breakdown of how you do that and
it allows people to breathe but you know
there's something about the human spirit
dave when they get all intense it's hard
to turn that down
especially those nerds like me right
yeah i mean we're so task oriented and
man that's what her husband's doing
jennifer's in sacramento hi jennifer how
are you
hi i'm doing good how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well i am i'm trying to figure out what
i should do with my
extra funds that i um have i currently
have a psp account it's about 156 000
and um i have uh some of the half of the
funds
uh in g fund 84 000.
yeah i know but the other half the csmc
fund it's about 72
000 and i currently compute about
20 of my uh checks uh into my tsp
but i'm thinking i need to make some
sort of change because
i'm putting i'm also putting out 500 a
month savings just to a regular checking
account and i want to maximize my
retirement
you're you're a rock star man you're
getting after it kiddo what do you make
i make about 79 000 a year good for you
do you own a home
well uh my husband he uh he just paid
off his house like two years ago
i'm sorry do you live with your husband
yes i do
he i say his house because he bought it
before we were married
oh but now it's your house okay
yeah okay so you so we just paid off our
house so you're debt-free house and
everything your
your family is correct yes correct
neither one of you you or your husband
have any debt then
uh well i uh i just wrote a check i'm
planning to
uh pay off my lexus i owe about fourteen
thousand dollars
but i'm gonna go ahead and check off
today good and i do have
a ten thousand dollar extra um that i'm
saving for my daughter
but i think i also need to move that to
somewhere else as well
okay how old is your daughter what are
you saving for college
um just i guess for her future whatever
she needs like a vehicle
or college i'm just worried about
college
putting into a 529 plan or a college
savings plan
if what if she doesn't go to school why
wouldn't she go to school
i don't know just worry yeah put it in
529 keep the government's hands off of
it get with a
smartvestor pro at daveramsey.com
they'll help you do that
as far as your tsp goes i recommend
eighty percent into the c
twenty percent into the s and twenty
percent into the i the s is the small
company the i is the international
c is the common stock that little
portfolio mix right there will
outperform any other mix in the tsp
and it's you could put it on the sea but
i want a little of the sauce in there
the small
and the international as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the debt-free stage in the ramsey
solutions lobby
sam and jasmine are with us hey guys how
are you
good how are you welcome where do you
guys live san antonio texas
oh fun welcome to nashville good to have
you guys
so here to do a debt-free scream how
much did you pay off
paid off 135 000 whoa
how long did this take uh 21 months wow
whoa
and your range of income during that
time we started at 123
to 204 just within the last few months
though
that's uh kind of ridiculous i love it
so what do y'all do for a living
i work in the i.t industry for the us
government okay
and i work in management for a shipping
and delivery company so who got the
mammoth raise both of you a little bit
of both of us
yeah big sam big sam i.t stepped up here
with big sam
way to go sam thank you man that's cool
y'all so what kind of debt was this 135
000
um it was a little bit of medical two
vehicles and
my student loans what was the big chunk
my student loan
and what did you owe on the student
loans um about 70
000 okay so about half of it was that
okay
cool cool how long you guys been married
one year tomorrow one year oh
congratulations so you started on this
before
yes and finished after you were married
yes yes okay so tell us the story how
did this all go down
so yes i did start it uh myself um
we had heard a very good many principles
through our pastor at church
and we just never really applied it to
our lives and
over time we saw that he would offer
financial peace university
um once again we didn't apply it and
months later a co-worker actually gave
me your book um
once again i didn't read it didn't apply
it um
it wasn't until um we got engaged that i
started watching your youtube videos
and that's when it finally clicked that
i really wanted to follow these
principles and that meant
that i would have to or we would have to
combine our income
um and that i would actually have to
reveal my debt to him
so you were already engaged before he
found out how much debt you had
actually knows right before it was
before
okay that was actually once i saw once i
had it in me to tell him and i saw that
he didn't have
a negative reaction to it like i thought
he would um that's when i knew that we
were in this together and okay
so you had 70 000 student loan debt you
had a car loan and sam had a car loan
yes yes okay and sam what other debt did
you have
that was it just like it was just my car
yes and how did you own your car
uh at the time twenty thousand okay
so you should this uh beautiful woman is
looking at you saying
uh with all this beauty comes a hundred
thousand plus in debt
yeah yeah and i was you know what'd you
do before i asked
you oh my god no you know i said there
was a lot of prayers
to god so i mean a lot of it was a faith
driven
and i knew what i was getting into
before i popped the question so
he was in love yeah he was well listen
we get anybody that can see
you out punted your coverage
so i got a question sam did you had you
heard a financial piece
we know she had i'm assuming you're in
the same church or am i assuming wrong
okay yes i had
um throughout going to church um
and then when we met we got together um
we started going to church together and
for me it was just kind of a
oh i never really had a solid plan but i
was never
really in debt aside from just a car so
um i had savings but i never threw my
savings to pay off my car
and so it was it was kind of a different
yeah yeah sure
yeah different situation yeah for sure
which church
um revolution church oh yeah in schertz
texas
fun it's very cool well way to go you
guys
y'all are impressive impressive young
couple very well done who are your
biggest cheerleaders outside the two of
you going yes you can do this
you know we didn't really publicize it
um
we feel like we just kind of had our
heads down and none of your family knew
you were working on this
um we kind of would mention it if it
would come up in conversation
and they were they were supportive but
but nobody's just like yes yes yes
right correct oh wow very cool so you
guys just struck out how old are you two
i am 36 and uh before her
um it's her birthday today happy
birthday
all right she's 28. all right very good
very birthday the day before the
anniversary yeah
very nice well you won't forget that
that's i was getting ready to see you
exactly
helpful it'll be helpful in your in
coming years they'll be glad for that
now you're not a budget it's because
that's the double hit right there
you got a plan for that oh yeah it's a
big month yeah i've got to ask him dave
what i mean that's a lot of money 135
000 in 21 months what was the biggest
sacrifice what was the big
hard part the hard stuff
uh to be honest there was no
hard part for us
it just wasn't having a plan and so when
we discovered
the um baby steps your baby steps
and followed through and implemented
with that plan we had the discipline we
had the attitude and the willpower
um everything just clicked and fell into
place wow
so and like i said when i started i
didn't really have a plan i had savings
but
only had a car debt and you know i
didn't know where to go yeah and so when
she
discovered the baby steps and everything
and said hey let's get on board with
this
i couldn't fully commit because we
weren't 100 we weren't married
and that was part of the principle to
combine our finances we had to get
married
and so i knew part of what god
gave me the vision to do was hey mary
this marry this woman if you really love
her and you know
and that's that's where we went from
there well done
good for you good stuff guys very very
cool
you guys are absolute heroes so proud of
you so what are you gonna do fun
next now that you're finally out of debt
we actually
um are in the process of building a home
so that's what we're looking forward to
good very cool when will it be completed
um hopefully by the end of this year
this year okay all right so perfect
timing good for you guys
thank you and you're doing everything
right you are really rocking this is
good stuff
well we've got a copy of the book the
legacy journey for you that's the next
chapter in your story to continue to
build out your legacy to live like no
one else so later you can live and give
like no one else and uh of course also
we're gonna give you a copy of the total
money makeover book
the one that you didn't read and uh the
first time anyway
but now you can give it away to somebody
and they won't read it and
the total money makeover is the most
used coaster on coffee tables all over
america
it sits there people put coffee cups on
it don't read it until the time is right
and then they crack that thing open and
it blows their minds and they go do it
it may sit there three years and collect
dust and coffee cup rings but finally
it's there
so it's just for you guys we love you
guys i'm so proud of y'all you guys are
impressive
very impressive very very proud of them
good job good job good job
all right sam and jasmine from san
antonio
135 000 paid off in
21 months making 123 to
204 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Applause]
man that's fabulous and not only are
they impressive they're pretty
yeah i'm not sure sam's okay with that
adjective but uh
yeah he understands what you mean but
yeah what a great
couple what a sharp sharp power couple
right there man a lot of fantastic going
on
lots of future there that's going to be
unbelievable and you know what's so
interesting is we give people
uh you know our last debt free scream in
the other hour fifty thousand dollars
here
this couple making 123 up to just
recently
after they're debt-free moving on up to
204.
all kinds of incomes do this yeah people
do it that are young people do it that
are
old uh people do it that uh live in the
west people do it that live in the east
uh people even people in california do
it
yeah it's absolutely it's amazing i mean
people everywhere
it's it's amazing you can actually
do this stuff these baby steps work this
is a proven process
financial peace university is a proven
process in ramsey plus
you can get in it you can change
everything folks so the only question is
when are you
going to do it the people that are
listening right now i'm talking to you
[Music]
when are you going to take control of
your destiny
it's up to you the cavalry's not coming
biden's not going to change your life
you have to do it and the great news is
you can this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
ramsey personality ken coleman host of
the ken coleman show
now heard on over 75 radio stations a
very popular podcast and siriusxm radio
joins me today answering your questions
about your careers
your jobs your life i'm here to help you
with your life and your money
and together we're going to make it done
get it get er done for you
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five father john is in oklahoma
hi father john how are you
i'm good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey i'm a big fan my parents learned me
on the ramsay method when i was a
teenager and
i i'm definitely convinced that uh
your methods really changed the
trajectory of my life so i just wanted
to say thank you
well thank you i'm honored how can we
serve you today sir
so i'm uh i'm a roman catholic priest
and i live in the housing that's
provided
by the parish and so i don't own a home
i've never been in debt and i
i am kind of in between baby steps uh
four and five and i was just kind of
i was just sort of wondering because of
how busy i am with ministry and
and also the possibility of kind of you
know i could get moved
anytime anywhere on the western half of
the state
um i just that's that's the primary
reason why i decided to
kind of not take up a mortgage and not
get a home and
and i haven't decided necessarily you
know if i'm
i don't have children of my own and so
i'm not sure if i'm going to be
saving up for my nieces and nephews or
not
but i guess what i was just wondering
was so right now i just
i'm you know i'm paying into uh
retirement and uh
and just kind of saving money i own my
car
and i'm just wondering you know is there
any reason why i should
uh why i should get a home or i'd be i
just
yeah i figured that there's some kind of
now i uh uh
so there's two questions i have that i'm
not familiar enough with the
roman catholic priesthood to and you'll
have to help me with this in my
ignorance
how often do they typically move you
so we can be moved uh well for us
younger priests we can get moved pretty
pretty regularly but um probably
anywhere between
five to ten years so you usually stay in
a place five or ten years
yeah okay okay that's the norm anyway i
mean obviously they can
anytime is what you've said twice but
the point is they typically
don't on the on a whim and you got a
five years so
you're there long enough to own a
property um
if you want especially once you've
settled into a parish that you think
you're going to be there
for an extended period of time that
might be a little bit later
in your career now the second thing and
this is going to sound really dumb but i
just don't know so i have to ask
okay you said you're saving for
retirement
i don't i didn't i don't know if
catholic roman catholic police should
retire do you
quit well yeah see that's the thing it's
kind of uh
uh retirement and air quotes um okay
we kind of just i was kind of under the
impression you didn't no
you know the the retirement age
technically speaking is 75 but
i mean i just plan on dying with my
boots on so yeah
yeah that's the the priests that i have
known that's what they've done
but i'm not uh roman catholic and so i
wasn't up close enough to know what the
flip was really going on so okay
all right that makes sense all right so
yeah you're saving for retirement now
here's what the reason i asked that is
as you move into uh maybe the second
half of your career
a you're more stable in a location and b
you're going to want to stabilize the
most expensive part
but potentially of your of your
retirement years i mean if you step out
of the parish and don't have
parish housing at 75 but continue doing
priest
priestly work of some kind but you don't
have the housing furnace you're going to
need a home
at that point and that is the biggest
line item in your budget at retirement
that's now destabilized because now
you're a renter and if we don't plan for
this
so i want you to plan to buy a house
65 years old and pay cash for it
okay or something something like that
you see what i'm doing here
so that you're we know by then you're
probably in a location you're going to
stay
and we know by then that there's a
possibility somewhere out in the fairly
near future that you might need housing
does that make sense yeah that doesn't
make sense i just i kind of you know i'd
always i was like
you know do these how do i navigate
these steps you know
housing's provided and how old are you
now
i i'm 30 today cool well happy birthday
yes
all right thank you well thanks for your
service to the lord sir
and uh thank you very much david yeah
and so yeah so what you're gonna do is
you're gonna start paying a house
payment into a mutual fund and that's
your house fund
that you're gonna pay cash with 30 years
from now okay
okay awesome well thank you very much i
appreciate you all taking my call yeah
thanks for bearing through my ignorance
because i don't know how these things
work
so cool that's fun it's really fun
because i want people to grab that when
you start putting a house payment right
now into a mutual
fund 30 years from now he's going to
have plenty of housing
he's going to be in really good shape
he's going to have a lot of money on
morning age yeah that's exactly right
that's a wonderful opportunity but
his his is truly a life of service yes
most of our lives should be but he's um
yes a different
different kind of commitment that he
stepped into there before god and very
powerful
very cool what a nice young man very
sharp open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
tina is in cincinnati
hi tina welcome to the ramsay show hi
there
um i have an insurance question um i'm
going to i'm going to be 59 and my
husband is going to be 49
and we took out 20-year term policies
that are going to be
running out in about six years
so i'll be able to retire at that point
but then my
husband will still have 10 more years of
working
and he won't have any term insurance
left
now our house will be paid off next year
and we're otherwise debt-free
and we have about 650 000 in our
retirement accounts right now
so he doesn't think that we'll need that
he'll need to replace that insurance
because
the house will be paid off and our
savings will take care of any needs
what is your 650 000 invested in
um it's our retirement plans our 401ks i
know what's in mutual funds
yeah okay if it's in good growth stock
mutual funds that are averaging
if they were to average 10 about every
seven years
they'll double if you don't add anything
to it
so seven years from now when we're
discussing about this six year policy
running out
you should have 1.3 million dollars in a
paid for house
if your husband dies honey i think
you're gonna be okay
watch what he says well i mean you think
you could struggle through on a million
three in a paid for house
yeah i probably could i just was just a
little nervous
just not knowing you know how things go
so it makes me feel i mean if
you have if six years from today if the
money has not grown
you can revisit the discussion right but
yeah but hypothetically you should be
you should be
uh you know self-insured
meaning no debt there's no money that
you need and you have a huge
pile of money over here to live off of
the income that it creates
so what's your household income now so
right now it's about 200 okay all right
you would have to live on about 130 if
he died
and you only had a million three but you
wouldn't have a house payment
correct yeah i don't know if you can do
that or not you think you can
i think so
[Laughter]
well here's the thing your fear is
justified
and it's a good fear the trick to use
the fear for
is to dig in and go okay what are the
facts
and can the fear go away once i
understand the facts
yeah and that's what i'm trying to lay
out here is because
it is very wise of you to be concerned
about this issue
people who are not concerned about how
things are going to go if someone dies
are the ones that end up messed up they
end up in a
really screwed up situation so you're
very wise to have that fear
but you're then you you know then what
you have to do is you have to do the
actual analysis
and it's okay for you to not say oh i
don't necessarily trust it just because
he says it
um you know you need to look at the
actual numbers don't do it because dave
ramsey said
but if you say okay looks like we're
going to have a talk to my financial
advisers we're going to have a million
and a half
paid for house six years from today
we'll let that drop i think we'll be
okay
and you can you can let that release
down inside of you then
beautiful thing thanks for calling
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
where they talk about careers and
finding your passion in your work
is my co-host today we're taking your
calls about careers about money about
life
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five five karen's in lubbock texas hi
karen how are you
hi dave hi ken it's an honor to speak
with you all
you too what's up um
my question is this i am in baby steps
four and five
and i have a 23 year old son he will be
going to graduate school in dallas
um in august and he's going to get a
free scholarship for all the two
thousand dollars of his graduate school
however i'll be helping him pay for
his rent and when he gets rent there
when he rents
his house he will
be having roommates and
if i am asked to co-sign i know i've
heard you say many times not to
co-sign for somebody when they're
renting for your child
so my question is
what can i do um if i'm asked to co-rent
what other
options would i order to co-sign what
other options would i have
are you paying the rent
um i'm going to help him he'll probably
be paying some of it but i'm going to
pay
um help him with a lot of it do you have
the money
yes i do i'm on baby steps four and five
and um
cash flowing he's 23. okay and what's
his grad work
he's going to a graduate in music
performance
okay is he working while he's in doing
his grad work
yes he will be he's in undergrad he did
a lot of gigs
and um you know he did a lot of work and
he did
he paid for most of it most of his rent
and
um yeah i paid for minimal of his school
so i won't be paying a whole lot but
the issue is i i'm just concerned that
when he gets a roommate he doesn't have
any credit or credit cards thank god
but if i'm asked to co-sign for him
the answer is no i would not co-sign for
anyone under any circumstances
the reason i was asking so many
questions i was trying to figure out
where you were in a couple of things on
parallels so um one of my kids at
college
moved into a house with a bunch of other
kids
and a i didn't want his name
or my name uh tied to being liable
for the whole rent if the other goobs
didn't pay their share
right which happens in college
situations all the time
okay yes and so what i did in that case
was i called the landlord talked to him
and i just prepaid
his rent for the year okay no signature
required
uh no lease required that we're he's
liable for the whole thing
because he's not liable for anything his
part's already paid
and i'm certainly not signing anything
yes i
yeah that's what um that's what i i just
wanted to be prepared when that question
arises
so and i don't want to burst your bubble
but i do want you to be thinking about
something and your son
why do you need graduate level work and
performance
in the music business
he his ultimate goal
is to be a professor to get a doctor
okay then that would make sense all
right that's the only reason i can think
you would want to get that
but you certainly don't need it to be a
performer like
the number of performers who have a
graduate degree
that stand on the stage and perform
music is
zero in fact there's a high percentage
of those performers don't even have a
college degree right um dave i had a
question there
you know i'm a little old school i i
don't know
why the 23 year old's not able to pay
his rent
a hundred percent i appreciate mom she's
awesome she's amazing
she wants to help clearly this young man
did a great job in college of paying for
most of his college and he has no debt
but at 23 i want my kid if he's going to
grad school i want him paying his own
rent
am i am i an archaic
old no i mean if she's funny no no
you're not
that that's preferable and she she's you
know she said he's a hard worker and
he's basically yeah he's absolutely
responsible he's not his kid's not him
right he's not a parasite
so um you know yeah i i think uh but but
to say absolutely zero
you know i might help i might have
helped one of mine in that situation
but my first and best choice for them is
for them to figure out a way to cut
cut their own way through the forest
yeah
you know get get the axe out get the
machete out time for you to do your own
thing baby doll
yeah and uh it's good it's good for that
that's not a bad thing at all
patrick's in tulsa oklahoma hi patrick
how are you
hey mr ramsay thanks for taking the time
to talk to me today sure what's up so
my question um fundamentally is
i finish your total money makeover book
my mother wants me to have a credit card
i do not want to have one how are you i
don't want to
uh 28 soon to be 28. so
background information that's sweet that
you're what your mommy wants but who
gives a rip
right right so background background my
mommy wants me to buy a red car too but
i'm 28 and i'll freaking buy a blue car
okay so i just finished medical school
i'm going to start residency here in a
little bit i have 158 000
of debts i haven't had a regular income
based
job i've been able to pay off my
undergrad loans
but now i'm just with med school student
loans and my parents have been gracious
enough
to put me up and basically pay for all
my costs of living
while i handle tuition so i want to be
able to
answer my mom respectfully other than
hey i'm 28 it's my life
thanks for helping me through but i'm
not gonna do that
yeah um you know all you have to do is
turn up the respect
one quarter of a notch to what you just
said and you'll be respectful uh
because she's out of line
she's out of line yeah i've got a 30
year old i would no more tell him that
than fly the moon
you know and i'm freaking dave ramsey i
mean really
so um you know so that that's just
that's that's a boundary violation and
uh
and so uh but anyway we want to be mean
to her they're being kind to you they've
been good to you and
we want to be loving and and gentle that
that that's not i'm not trying to be
sarcastic and mean but so the answer is
mom i've been reading through this and
uh this new material
and i've become convinced that our
debt-based way of doing things in
america is a bad plan
and so i'm just really scared about
these student loans that we're going
into here
and one of my first goals is going to be
get rid of those and i'm swearing off a
debt
i'm not going to go anywhere near debt
and so i've got a debit card
it'll do everything a credit card will
do except go into debt and i'm not going
into the debt mom
and you ought to really be proud of me
for that because it means you raised me
well
and uh that's it nice ton of discussion
yeah
and if she can't put it down and she
won't um
then that's on her at that point that's
not on you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month to get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey
to save 50 off your first month pure
talk
simply smarter wireless
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life
and your money chase is with us in
dallas
hi chase welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave and ken thank you guys so much
for taking my call
sure what's up well uh first off i
wanted to thank you uh for
last year i called in in february last
year with the business question i was
looking at a partnership
and uh you strongly encouraged me not to
do it and uh
i wanted to thank you because my
business has about tripled in size over
the last year
wow and um it's been it's been a banner
year i run an appraisal firm and it's
been
very busy so good for you thank you for
that first i'm so happy for you my
question
oh thank you so much my question today
is
um we are thinking about getting into a
bigger home
and honestly i'm a little bit nervous we
are on baby step
four five and six and we currently have
a home
that is it's a very affordable home i
don't even think about my mortgage but
it is in a school district
that we don't really love i have four
kids that are
starting at ages three and go up to
eight so we have a lot of little kids at
home and we got them piled into the
three bedrooms
so it's a bit of a mad house and
we are looking at moving to a better
school district but the homes there are
quite a bit more expensive than what i
have and um
we have an opportunity we had not only
did we find a house down there we found
a house
on land um that needs some repairs done
to it but
the house is down in their range from
kind of the 350 to the 475 range
and after repairs and everything this
thing would be
right about 350. so it's kind of a kind
of an ideal situation
my question is should i wait and be a
little bit more conservative
because i'm a business owner or am i in
the right place to start moving up in
house
as long as the mortgage is on a 15-year
fixed or less and it's no more than a
fourth of your take-home pay
i'm good with the move okay
okay um well the only thing that kind of
put a little monkey ring to that is that
i know that you're
you're not big into uh financing or
doing any kind of uh
uh anything for repairs on the house and
the house does need that we need about
seventy thousand dollars of repair but
we could put that
into the 15-year fixed rate mortgage and
i would just have yeah
that's like doing a construction loan to
build a house yeah at that point and i
don't i'm not against that
it just all ends up in your permanent is
what it amounts to now what is your what
is the years left on your current
mortgage
how many years left so i've got about we
we refinanced to a 15 year last year so
i've got 14 years i only owe about a
hundred thousand dollars on it the house
is
worth about a little less than 200 000
okay and you're gonna throw that hundred
in the mix and so you're gonna finance
250 give or take on a 15-year fix
instead of a hundred so you're going up
a hundred and a half and your household
income is what
well my household income i don't know if
i should judge it off this last year but
we again it was a big year so it was
about 250 000
um this last year the year before was
about 200. yeah
you're more than okay dude i mean you're
in great shape
my wife is going to laugh at this call
she
thinks i'm the most conservative person
on planet earth i build our budget
around 100
you're not but if they die you could be
left with that title
oh no you're you're doing good you're
just being very careful and you're very
wise you're
you're an appraiser and so you're a
numbers guy and you're
you're a detail guy and you and you
analyze things on the left side of the
brain and that's awesome
there's nothing wrong with any of that
it's gotten to work gotten you to where
you are dude so it's not a bad gig
you're doing a really really good job
i'm proud of you um you're in good shape
here
the trick is to just not get in patterns
that roll you into more debt all the
time
and so this is this is probably a a big
move for at least a decade and you're
probably going to get this house paid
off in about less than 10 years
that is the plan yeah that's a you're in
good shape dude chase one last piece of
advice
it'd be good to go home and tell your
wife that you talked to dave and
she was right let's get some bonus
points there but you're still a good
dude
you're doing great you you've done a
great job analyzing it
and your your conservative nature has
gotten you to where you are but it's
also good to
uh bounce things around and you're open
you're humble enough that you're open to
input from her input from other people
and just to kind of bounce things around
think it through with other people
that's very wise
very very wise good question man thank
you for joining us congratulations on
all your success
very very well done folks if you're
tired of feeling stuck with your money
like you'll never get out of debt or
you'll never save enough for the future
maybe you'll never be in control like
that guy was
listen it doesn't have to be that way
you can make progress with your money
and you can make it faster than you
think
the only way to make it happen is with a
budget and that's why you need a ramsey
plus membership you'll get
access to the premium version of our
every dollar budgeting app which is
world class
you plan out every dollar you'll spend
you'll save before the month begins
connect your budget to your bank so you
don't miss a transaction custom budget
reports
access to financial peace university
access to coaching access to group
discussions
it is an amazing process to get into
ramsey plus
when you budget and you get intentional
with your money you're going to make
progress
fast and you can start budgeting for
free
today with a free trial at ramsey plus
text
trial to 33789 text trial
233 seven eighty
nine our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure or you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best possible deal
dave today's question comes from kendall
in kentucky i will get my bachelor's in
business management
next year and i have roughly 40 000
invested in the stock market
and three months expenses in my
emergency fund i'm considering going
straight into a master's program in data
business analytics i don't think i will
have the skills to confidently walk into
a data analytics job
with a bachelor's degree should i stay
in school to get my masters or
should i work full-time in a different
role for a couple years and save up more
money
to go back to school for data analytics
well the first thing is
uh let's get for sure when somebody says
i don't think i'll have the skills i
hear a little bit of doubt
and the way we deal with doubt is we go
get some facts and i think there are
many
entry-level jobs that will lead you into
data analytics and so i would do my
research
you've got a school that can help you
and get you a ton of information plus
you have relationships will allow you to
talk to people who are winning
in data analytics that's the proximity
principle it says in order to do what i
want to do data analytics
i got to get around people that are
doing that work and in places where it's
happening
that is your number one homework
assignment let's get very clear
on whether or not you must get a
master's degree
in order to do the work you eventually
want to do
anybody that gets out of college has got
to jump in at entry level and i don't
think you are
not going after this master's degree
because you need a master's degree
you're going out this master's degree
because you're scared to be a grown-up
yes you want to hide in the education
because you're afraid of stepping out
there in a real freaking world dude
throw your shoulders back son and go get
you a job
and get into data analytics data
analytics is the hottest
i mean that and and and security cyber
security right now two of the hottest
fields out there
you're going to make so stinking much
money and you're gonna learn on the job
because data
analytics is moving at light speed
faster than the professor is teaching at
the master's level
he already doesn't know what you need to
know a month from now yeah
you can't keep up by going in and doing
formal education in that field son
you're gonna have to get in the field
and you're gonna get out there kick the
can and cause stuff to happen
don't be scared go do it throw your
shoulders back and step into it son
you can do this yeah you're just trying
to hide behind you you know people don't
want to go out there they
just keep going to school it's time to
quit
time to go do it yeah and listen they're
training you on the job as you say
and and they'll pay for your masters if
you need it you don't i got data
analytics people all over this building
and they're smarter
they're smart than smart and smart and
smart almost none of them have a
master's
yeah that's exactly right they're
they're running freaking data for ramsey
i can tell you that
and we are data bonkers around this
building man they're teaching me stuff
every day
i'm so impressed with them they're very
smart people but they are not
masters degreed that's absolute bs
a bs is all you need not the degree
so i did there i like what you did all
right this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
lee and heather are with us along with
their daughter
sophia hey guys how are you hey dave
fantastic welcome where do you guys live
uh franklin indiana uh 20 minutes south
of
indianapolis so indianapolis very cool
now and your how much debt did you pay
off
91 251.95
love it how long did this take 25 months
good for you and your range of income
during that time we started at 143
went up to uh 162 and i actually just
got a promotion
last week so we're at 171 now wow
what do you do for a living so we both
work for the department of defense i'm
an hr
and i'm an i.t very cool good for you
good careers
what kind of debt was the 91 000
my student loans all of it all of it the
only debt you had
the only thing we had oh my gosh so
what's your degree in
hr uh yes i have an mba in hr
good for you good for you that's a great
degree yeah that's a great field
good for you that's so fun so uh how
long you guys been married
yeah almost 10 years all right good good
and what happened two years ago that set
this on fire
well it actually started about 14 years
ago i first no it didn't you've been
getting out of debt for 25 months
i first heard about you then and my life
was a mess i
had credit card payments and you know
medical bills and everything else
listened to fpu
and thought this made sense this is
smart
biblical wisdom started getting out of
debt and met this handsome guy
here and he was completely completely on
board
yes he uh one of the stipulations to
being together
she said you got to read your this book
and so it was total money makeover
you've been married 10 years yeah we
were so what happened
two years ago i thought you got out of
debt in 25 months
we did so i'm so confused
so we decided you know um after we were
un we actually were
both laid off for a year and a half
after he came back from
iraq he was injured and couldn't work i
lost my job at the same time
so we kind of had to stop everything and
rebuild
our careers and all our assets
and then 25 months ago we said enough on
the student loan we're sick of it
we need to get rid of it and we went
nuts the first year we paid off 25 000
and then last year we paid 66 000.
amazing
that's impressive okay so you went
through a career downturn
and a reset of your whole lives and
following that
is when the 25 months started right and
now i'm getting my story yeah
i got a degree a bachelor's degree in
the time because i couldn't do my job so
the va paid for it uh and i was like
what do i what do i want to do that i
love so that's why i chose it
good for you that's smart good choice uh
i got a ray i got a promotion like a 20
000 promotion and 17 and then we're like
you know we're barely paying on this
debt so
let's pay we make money let's pay what
the max
yeah and so that's when we kind of like
yeah what are we doing let's get
let's get that book back out now yeah
okay all right cool so you were in the
military then
uh yes i was okay and how did you get
injured um
overseas my back um oh yeah i just kind
of messed my back up so i had three back
surgeries one hip surgery
oh i have a service dog actually uh he's
at home
so yeah i was a mechanic and that's what
i was doing
i injured myself and i just couldn't do
it anymore uh so
va say we'll pay for your degree uh so i
chose it because i really i loved yeah
i.t and so i really very wise thank you
for your service
yes sir very neat i want to point out
something really quick here for folks
that are listening
lee had a a physical change and so he
had to make a career change as a result
of a physical thing that's not something
you picked
but that mechanical brain tied in
beautifully to the i.t
fixing problems the way you can break
stuff down is that right it was a really
nice easy transition for you though yeah
like it's still technical and stuff so
that's right it was just a different
kind of technical
yeah good for you man great transition
there's the heaviest thing you have to
lift the keyboard though
yeah that's good i like it that's smart
man i love it you guys are incredible
you're heroes
how does it feel now that you're finally
free
unbelievable kind of still it's still
kind of new
so maybe after we scream we'll know i
don't know yeah we're just like okay
we're just going to go continue
it's like nothing's changed we need to
do our savings
we need to save up for things so we
don't want to lose that momentum
we did uh we went out to eat uh
you know we said hey we deserve let's go
out to eat you know
so yeah and then we did that and we're
just gonna continue to go yeah
moving on along so yeah finish up baby
step three now get your emergency fund
in place and then
become wealthy oh yeah very well done
good job you guys what do you tell
people the secret to getting out of debt
is
i'd say the budget communication and
prayer
really works yeah all right hey man yeah
i would say
uh just sticking to it you can have a
you can have a budget and you have your
blueprints but if you just put walls
wherever you want
it then it's not nothing's gonna matter
so you just gotta stick to your budget
and so uh that's one of the key things i
i notice people they're like oh yeah we
have a budget
and they just spend and spend and you
just gotta really
keep to the budget yeah okay if it's on
paper this is what we're going to do
and just keep them going heather you
really focused on prayer for what you
really
locked in pause there what'd you pray
about specifically what prayers were
answered in this process
strength there you go that's a good one
um
just intentionality and just
understanding that this is a season and
that god has so much more planned for us
as a family
and how much we can contribute now that
we don't have this chain around our
ankle anymore
wow that that'll preach i think our jobs
too because
we were in a situation where we didn't
know what we're going to eat we had to
go to the like the the food market
pantry
to get some food sometimes wow we were
unemployed and i just had my
the va was paying me to get a degree it
was the only thing that
really helped us and so it's like you
know we thank the lord every day
for our jobs our house our cars all
these things yeah
and so it's just amazing how like to
reflect on that
hey man very powerful good for you guys
way to go i'm so proud of you who are
your biggest cheerleaders outside the
three of you
um well i i physically facilitate
financial peace at church so um
constantly doing that
uh we just wrapped up our 10th class
yeah so you got to do it when you're
gonna do it yeah when you're leading it
that's the ultimate accountability right
right
but the class is cheering you on too
right yeah absolutely because i know
you're here today
they do i love it and we've met so many
friends
through the class and now they're in our
small group uh because of that class and
then
become like our best friends yeah
because it's just this class that we
taught
and so it's amazing how the lord works
in that way too amen
amen you know some of the very first
people that i taught years ago with a
bad suit and overhead projector i still
stay in touch with them
it's pretty cool and that was 30 years
ago awesome way to go you guys
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter
in this story to live like no one else
so now you can live and
give like no one else leave that legacy
well done and an extra copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away
sounds like you got lots of places you
could possibly do that
and uh pay it forward get somebody else
involved and that's good stuff so
congratulations all right lee and
heather and sophia from indianapolis 91
000 paid off in 25 months
making 143 to 171 recent raise
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
hey three two one
[Applause]
that's how it's done
interesting how much adversity they came
through
and how the entire time they're talking
about they're smiling yes
absolutely there was there was no sour
yeah you know not weaned on a pickle it
was like yeah we did that
and we did that and we did that and i'm
like my god and you're still smiling
you're smiling about it i mean it's
pretty impressive
it you know it's it's a result of the
sun comes out after the storm
and they're in the sun right now and and
that feels really nice when you've been
through
the wind and the hail and the tornadoes
and the hurricanes and all that
to come out on the other side it's sunny
and joy comes in the morning that's what
we see there
amen this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture today philippians 4 6
don't worry about anything instead pray
about everything
elon musk says when something is
important enough
you do it even if the odds are not in
your favor
amen and amen good stuff open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
whitney's with us in las vegas hi
whitney how are you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
thank you for taking my call so i just
had a question so i'm
debt-free besides my mortgage i actually
just bought a house
um i contribute i match my company's
401k
and i just started go um contributing to
our iri
i was wondering if you were familiar
with or you know
of the app acorns i've been also like
putting money into that
and i was just wondering your views on
that if that's a good
if you've heard anything about it if you
would suggest doing that or
no well the premise is that it's a small
amounts that go in correct
yeah so it'll it can round up like
connected to your bank account but i
also put in money out you know a couple
hundred or if i have extra i try to put
it in but
is it you know something that would be
good on i feel like it is just like an s
p right it just follows the same market
but you're not putting amount enough
money in there that it matters i mean
i've got a coffee cup
um an old coffee cup that sits on my
dresser
and i put the change out of my pocket in
it
but it's not going to make me rich right
but if it's something it kind of grows i
mean no it doesn't it's not going to
make me rich it's just
it's a coffee cup full of change what
makes me rich is what you're doing on
the other stuff when you're putting
thousands of dollars in your 401k in
your roth iras
not nickel and dime roundups right
okay so it's almost just kind of just
like another joke
yeah it is because it's a small amount
and if you put in a small amount
even if it did really well it's going to
end up being a small amount
the the only danger with it is it makes
you feel like you're actually doing
something
right right and that's laughable would
you suggest getting like what the smart
investor pro and then starting like
the mutual funds that you said if you
want to put more into investments you
need to do
real investing and put a put a
substantial amount in
what would you say is like a substantial
amount i mean
i mean you're putting 15 of your income
away and you're in baby step four right
yes so you would not put more away now
other than kids college unless you have
a more if you have a mortgage to pay off
do you have a mortgage to pay off
i i have a mortgage yet then you need to
be putting all extra nickels and dimes
towards the mortgage
above 15 of your income towards
retirement
absolutely let me tell you this is not
just dave ramsey so let's back up okay
that
there's a reason that i'm telling you
that and if you understand the reason
maybe it'll be helpful okay
we did the largest study you've probably
heard me talk about a thousand times
ever done on millionaires in north
america over 10 000 millionaires were
surveyed
the typical plan that came out of that
was
the vast majority of them they had
two major components of becoming
millionaires
they were investing steadily a large
chunk of their income like 15 as an
example
into their 401ks and roth iras the
second thing they did was they had a
paid for house
those two items added together made up
over a net worth of over a million
dollars
for the vast majority over 80 percent of
them followed that plan
and out of 10 000 of them that we
interviewed
the number that said that they became
millionaires because
they saved nickels and dimes with acorn
was precisely zero
right okay but would did you say once
that
investing in your 401k you should only
go up to what they match
and then you know do an ira yeah you
should do if
you should do match first roth second
traditional third does your 401k have a
roth option
yes okay then you would do your 401k
with roth
take the match if you're for does your
401k have
good mutual funds in it to select from
that i don't know i would have to look
okay if they're good mutual funds you
max the whole thing out and if that
doesn't get you to 15
then you can reach over into a roth ira
in addition to get you up to
15 of your income but the best thing you
can get is a match the next best thing
you can get
is tax-free growth which is roth the
next best thing is tax deferred
growth okay so match beats roth beats
uh traditional okay exactly that's the
deal so
you know take that match for sure and
and
then look at the mutual funds if they're
decent mutual funds just load that 401k
up what what is your income um
i'm in sales so it varies but 90 to 110.
okay you could you could be done with
your 15 than in a 401k
okay yeah you don't have to reach you
won't have to reach over the roth if
your 401k has good options because you
can put 15
000 401k allows up to 19 000 some change
this year
so you're you're fine yeah you can do it
all right there and i imagine you've got
decent options in that 401k most of them
do
now there's a few amount where we run
into our lousy mutual funds but most
people do a pretty good job of putting a
decent selection in there
the four types we talk about growth
growth and income aggressive go but you
don't really need a side investment fund
you need to be throwing those side
dollars that's a mortgage
that's my point it's a distraction dave
it's good marketing they've made people
think oh this is really wise
and there's just not the roi in it it
becomes a distraction
well yeah it's
you know if you plant a few kernels of
corn you're going to get
not much corn right
there you go if you plant a few acres
you're going to get a couple of trees
yeah yeah
but if you want a whole forest boys and
girls yeah okay you want the tree farm
you better plant a lot
[Laughter]
big money in tree farms dave so i hear
oh i got a friend of mine that's mega
wealthy he bought tree farms years ago
told me i was an idiot for not doing it
and he was looking like a genius
he's growing gold bars out there right
now dead gum lumber
it's not just a metaphor it turns out
there's actually real they're gold bars
with branches
i mean they're just unbelievable lumber
prices are through
he was already a billionaire and he is
twice over not just because of stupid
trees
it's unbelievable i'm so mad at him and
such a good i'm so proud of him but
he did make fun of me and now he's
really proven that he was right when he
made fun of me
just i'll never forget it and give him a
hard time at dinner the next time i've
seen him
uh michael is in boston hey michael
welcome
to the ramsay show hey dave thanks for
having me on
sure what's up um so i have a question
on tackling baby step
six so i recently paid off about 50 000
of debt 25 000 thank you
i have 25 000 in my emergency fund and i
have
close to 15 of my income
um since uh since i can't do full 15
because i would hit the 401k
cap um and when i'm looking at babysit
six my mortgage is like this massive
thing since i just got it in 2019 and
just the thought of putting everything
in there would take me years
uh to do to pay it off so my question is
what's your income um i make 170.
way to go what's this mortgage
um oh stop your whining dude you can do
this
you could totally do this you make 170
000. but
wouldn't you want to do some sort of
thinking fund for
unknown expenses or would you no an
unknown expert you make 170
000. you're a single guy
you're so awesome way to go man well you
have a fiancee
well you're okay you're not re you know
is she gonna mess this up or is she
gonna work with you
oh we're working together what does she
make
50. holy crap you're gonna be making a
quarter of a million dollars and you're
young not even 30.
yeah um so i guess then that's the
answer then just put
just throw it away seriously seriously a
hundred thousand dollars a year
in four years you're done this is not
exactly overwhelming
and then put everything and then you'll
be debt free and you'll just be making a
quarter million dollars and become
unbelievably wealthy
and unbelievably generous and if you
don't do a hundred thousand dollars a
year and you only do 75 000 it's gonna
take you five years
dude you really got this this is very
very very doable your stud
act like it you got this ken good show
thank you sir always fun james childs
great show madison great show i'm dave
ramsey your host we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace
christ jesus
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker
just tell alexa google assistant or siri
to play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you